-Our next guest tonight is
an Emmy Award-winning comedian,
director, and writer
you know from his work on
"Saturday Night Live" and as
one-third of The Lonely Island.
He is the author of
the new children's book
"Little Fox
and the Wild Imagination,"
which is available today.
Please welcome back to the show
our very good friend
Jorma Taccone.
How are you, Jorm?
-Hi. I'm so glad
you mentioned the Emmy because,
you know, it's right here!
-[ Laughs ] Oh, you have it!
You put the Emmy
in the background.
I think it'd be very nice
if people who are thinking about
buying a children's book
you wrote know what song
the Emmy is for.
-Uh, it was called
"Dick in a Box."
-[ Laughs ]
So, Jorm --
-It is a heartwarming tale.
It's a heartwarming tale.
-I want to start by
congratulating you on the fact
that you just became
a father again.
-I did. I did. Mere weeks ago.
-And your new baby girl,
correct?
-Yeah, Zany Quinn.
I wanted to name her
Quinn Elizabeth,
but Mari said that I couldn't
name our child a joke name.
-[ Laughs ]
I want to ask about Wylie,
your 5-year-old.
Is not only the inspiration for
this book, but he actually --
There's actual dialogue of
Wylie's in the book, correct?
-Yes. Sort of the impetus of
this book was --
It's obviously
the wild imagination
of my 5-year-old, Wylie,
but there was a quote
when he was 3 years old.
He would constantly say, "Now, I
will put you in a mail truck
and throw you in the ocean, and
a shark will eat you all gone,"
which was I think
his way of telling me
that he loved me very much.
-It is a very nice thing.
And I will say
you've got a fantastic
illustrator for this book.
There is Mail Truck and Shark.
And it must be so exciting
to see the art
come back for words like that,
especially words of your child.
-Well, you know this, because
I'm doing the comic-book thing.
I mean, like,
when you write something
and then have it visually come
to life, it's just incredible.
And this guy, Dan Santat,
the fact that he even agreed
to do this --
like, he's a Caldecott winner.
I couldn't believe that he was
even willing to be
involved with me.
I mean, you know, but "Dick in
a Box" I guess goes a long way
to certain people.
-[ Laughs ]
Something else
that goes a long way
with a lot of people
is "MacGruber."
You are one of the co-creators
of "MacGruber" as well,
with Will Forte
and John Solomon.
And you are very kind
because you are now working on
an eight-episode series
for Peacock
for fans of "MacGruber,"
of which there are legion.
And I believe I am
the front of that fan line.
We are very excited about this.
Where are you in the process?
-We've been writing Monday,
Wednesday, Friday every week.
And quite often we'll start
about a half an hour late
because Will's off
doing Sea Captain lines.
-Yes.
-So I'm pretty glad
that that's over.
-[ Laughs ]
-He would just be in
the background, like, you know,
this little --
"Arggh, weird transition."
But you would actually
get to hear, like,
the five different takes
that he would do.
-Yes, I think we both know
from our lucky collaborations
with Will
that he is a perfectionist.
And every day I would text him
and say,
"Look, if you don't have time,
you don't have to do
Sea Captain lines."
And, of course, he's also
very amenable to helping.
But I forget that he, of course,
was taking huge chunks of time
out of your day,
so I'm very sorry.
-And I'm being kind when I say
it was a half an hour.
It was usually more
like an hour.
-[ Laughs ]
Hey, I also owe you
thanks for this.
A few years ago your wife Mari
was directing a film
in Pittsburgh,
and my family goes to Pittsburgh
once a year,
and I told you it was for
my mother's birthday.
And so you came to
my mother's birthday party.
And you made her an airbrushed
picture with her face on it,
which is just genuinely great.
Also, it's very rare when
the person holding the shirt
is making the same expression.
[ Laughs ] But there it is.
And we tell everyone,
because you can't quite read it,
what the tagline
that you put on the shirt was.
-Oh, I believe the tagline was
"Real G's move in silence."
-[ Laughs ]
-Which, to me, said grandmas.
Real grandmas move in silence.
-I would love for you to have
seen the full conversation
with my mom when I tried to
explain to her
what "Real G's move in silence"
meant.
-[ Laughs ]
-One of the fans
of "MacGruber" --
and I was joking earlier --
the people who have
watched "MacGruber"
or are a fan of "MacGruber" is
one of our finest directors,
Christopher Nolan,
who directed "Batman,"
"Inception," among other things.
And he -- How did you find out
that Christopher Nolan was a fan
and did you ever get a chance
to talk to him about it?
-That was when Anne Hathaway
was on "Jimmy Fallon,"
and I got a call at the time
from the producer.
I believe it was Michael
Shoemaker, your producer,
who called and told me
that I had to watch
when Anne Hathaway was
on the show that night.
I watched,
and she told a story that was
when they were shooting
"Batman," she knew things
were going really well
when Christopher Nolan
started to quote "MacGruber,"
which was shocking to me
that he was a fan at all.
And then I went to
a directors dinner.
The DGA hosts
these directors dinners,
and me and my wife went
because she is a filmmaker,
a much better filmmaker than me.
And she was like,
"Oh, Christopher Nolan's here.
You got to go talk to him."
And so I ran up to him
and was like,
"Chris, I'm a director.
I did this movie 'MacGruber.'"
He's, like, "Oh, hi,"
and I was like,
"Yeah, we're thinking about
doing this sequel pretty soon,
and what do you
think about me putting,
when the director title
comes up,
it just says 'Christopher Nolan'
with an asterisk?
And then after the movie
another asterisk,
like a footnote comes up
and says who
really directed the movie."
And he was, like, "Well, you
know, I'll have to ask my wife."
[ Laughs ]
So we're still hoping.
I'm asking him if he wants to --
-I'm so confident that question
was never asked
to Christopher Nolan's wife.
"Honey, sit down. There's
a huge opportunity for us."
Hey, buddy,
congratulations again.
The book is really wonderful.
Not in jest at all.
Both my kids really loved it.
I'm so excited for "MacGruber."
And congratulations to you
and Mari on the new baby.
-Oh, thanks so much, and
congratulations for being back.
-It's nice to be back,
and we did make Forte
do a line tonight,
so I'm very sorry.
[ Laughs ]
-Ugh!
-"Little Fox and the Wild
Imagination" available today.
We will be right back.